good morning John it's Friday April 22nd
so I made a video for today and it's
already it's all edit it's ready to go
due to circumstances beyond my control
which I cannot explain to you at this
very moment I cannot put that video
online now I have to make another video
dad so since my planned video for today
kind of fell through now I have to make
a view in the old school way the way
that I used to do it where I just talk
to the camera hi this is a prop for the
video that was supposed to go online
today it's a hundred pennies in a car
and this is a prop from my nerd jokes
video it was around the lens I don't
actually keep my duct tape there maybe I
should it's a place to keep it that's
clutter speaking of props astute
nerdfighters who watch every one of my
videos thank you very much for doing
that I've recently noticed that my
posters the one that that's right there
seems to keep change and that is correct
I've been doing that for a while now
where I rotate through posters because I
feel like you know that's a space that I
can do interesting stuff with and that
is the map of the realm of non-being of
good nerdfighters who I appreciate
greatly if you've been around since the
rap with the malmö wrap of the mell if
you've been around since the map of the
realm of Narnia days I am amazed if you
don't know what I'm talking about love
that right there yeah that's a map of
the realm of Narnia good lord
I just went and watched that whole video
that was January 5th that was like my my
3rd video ever on YouTube Wow and that
co-starred with me I recently discovered
it was made in 1972 it's very it's
pretty old so I went along that thing
sells on eBay for like 80 to $100 and
it's not like I haven't been fond of the
map of the realm of Narnia but knowing
that it's worth 80 bucks found to be a
little bit more careful with it in the
future
so anyways posters I've decided that I
want more posters in my life so I'm
gonna do a rotation every video new
poster there and the first comment that
tells me what that poster is of you will
get nothing dftba records has not to
this point on posters but i am obviously
a fan of posters so i want to do posters
but we need some good poster designs so
i'm gonna be looking into that ideas for
good poster designs in the comments
please I have a tiny the cheat also I
got him along with my strong bed poster
wise my chair doing this
finally stopped I'm dizzy I should show
you my feet aren't touching the ground
leg crossing is one of my only stupid
human tricks I can get into a full Lotus
without without touching my hand now
you've seen my feet they're big and not
very attractive
yeah we were doing this for a long time
when I went back to check out the Narnia
video and really sort of hit home also
the amount of amazing stuff that has
happened to us
and that we have been able to accomplish
because of this this for example like
this is not something that I could have
done without why did my door just open
if I'd had this idea and I didn't have
nerdfighteria to sort of as a launching
platform for it I couldn't have done
anything with a nerdfighteria is there
to support me in the Harebrained Schemes
that I have and is everything from that
to like me humping stuff on tumblr yes I
know I didn't mention it in my last
video but don't worry I was impressed
no more serious stuff like the project
for awesome and the fact that I was able
to go to Haiti to examine the work that
nonprofit organizations are doing there
I sit here in this chair and make videos
I can't express how thankful I am for
that and this probably should be like
the video that I make when we get
500,000 subscribers when I'm like oh
thank you all but I don't need a special
occasion so somehow this video turn into
a thank-you video I would also like to
thank ticky-tacky for helping to fix my
posters to the walls 3m is not
sponsoring this video
I may have noticed we don't do much in
the way of sponsored videos why do i do
do sponsored videos when i have my own
things to sell speaking of my own things
to sell these are available on amazon
and i know not everybody has a PayPal
account or once a PayPal account so now
you can buy them on Amazon portal 2 is
going well I just uploaded the second
episode sorry it took me so long to get
it online but man is it fun John thank
you as well I hope you having a great
time in Amsterdam and I will see you on
Monday endscreen time I just wanted to
show you this picture I just found of
John Green this was when I was in
college so he was just out of college
and this is my dorm room in college we
had a dartboard that is the darks John
is throwing it and he is super freakin
skinny